Hello everyone give me a second.
I gotta, I gotta, I gotta get rid of,
get rid of the, my mercy theme.
Silence, silence.
You guys want to hear the game, right?
I'm a mama mama mama.
Oh no, wait, you can't even hear the game.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, I'm kind of dumb.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Oh, my bad.
How do I do this again?
Oh my gosh.
It's so funny, I'm like, yeah, I have everything ready.
I set up my controller.
I made sure everything's fine.
Of course I forget one thing.
Tee hee, pet up.
Oh, let's call this, uh, monitor sound.
I got so nervous I had to run to the bathroom.
I mean, I ran to my idle meeting.
Uh-huh.
Is this the one?
No, I set my idle meeting.
Shut up.
Did you wash your hands?
Of course I washed my hands.
Is this the right one?
Oh, that's bad, that's bad that I can't do this.
Where is my sounds?
Where's my monitor sounds?
Thank you.
Is this dumb?
Okay.
Hello?
Hello, hello?
You guys can hear it now, right?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
Yay.
Yay, yay, yay, yay, yay.
Okay, cool, cool, cool, cool.
How's the volume for everyone?
I'm gonna adjust my own volume
just so I can hear some more,
but the volume for a bit, a bit, it's a little different.
Some five?
Let me know, okay?
Okay, okay, okay.
It's all good, a little bit loud.
I can pull it down a little bit for, for,
for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for,
for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for,
for, for for, for, for.
For, for for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for for.
For, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for.
For, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for so good,
for, for, for, for, for.
For, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for, for for, for, for,
I want to play on normal.
You guys are not going to complain about normal, right?
My senpais aren't going to complain about normal, right?
Normal is fine.
I'm an auntie nausea pill, about 15 minutes before spring, so it should, it should kick in, yes.
Wait.
I forgot I'm using an Xbox controller!
Wow, dumbass!
Ahahaha!
Target Angel!
January 20th, 2010 winter.
Huh?
Look at him in his low wiggly fingers!
What is he wiggling at?
Is he going to tickle you?
Huh?
I can't read this.
Hahaha!
Oh, by the way, I am playing on the Xbox controller.
Um, I read that there's like mixed reviews on the controls, so I'm going to try my best.
Garcian Smith.
Did I totally butcher that name?
Hahaha!
Oh yeah, I set up dynamic lighting and everything, so we can have feels.
Oh, they're passing each other.
What are they passing?
Christopher Mills.
Is it drugs?
Is it a video game?
Kenchi Angel, thank you.
Is that, uh, what case is that for?
A violin?
Haha, passing the mixtape?
Yeah, check out my mixtape.
It's me.
So you there yet?
It's me!
Yeah.
That's where they all hang out.
Your information tells us that there's 14 of them.
14?
And they're all fun.
Nah, I keep one alive so we can ask for the bosses.
Anything else I shouldn't know?
No.
Not really.
You'll know when you see them, they're, uh, different.
What do you mean different?
We'll do one.
May the Lord smile.
And the devil have mercy.
Have you ever played Mass Effect?
No, I have very bad motion sickness, so this is my motion sickness training, everyone!
A free-for-all fight in the multi-purpose facility's Celtic Building, assignment number 33.
Destroy the Heaven Smile headquarters and capture the chief alive!
Hahaha!
I can do that.
Do you wish to learn the controls?
Yeah!
Use A to run.
Huh?
Oh!
Use B to change directions.
Use R...
Right trigger.
That was my left.
Ready your weapon.
Lock on your targets.
Use the...
Scan for enemies.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, wait, what?
Scan for enemies.
Oh!
Whoa!
Oh, wait, what?
Okay.
Wait a minute.
Like this?
Oh!
I understood!
I understood the assignment!
Hi, hi, hi, hi.
I understood.
Controls, stop being janky, thank you.
I understood!
Okay.
Anyone else?
No one else, right? There's like shadows of them!
.
Is there another person oh, what did I what did I do?
Can I go through the door? Let me let me in the door. Let me in the door. Let me in the door
Me in the door door door door door door door let me in
Dang it
Try scanning again, okay. Oh
Oh
There's new things there, okay, I got it. I got it fuck fuck you
Now they're coming close
What do you mean they crawl what do you mean they crawl
Oh
Okay
Use the eight around okay
I'm running! I'm running! I'm running! What else do you want from me, Mr. Gipman?
I didn't know that I was gonna get attacked!
Okay, do I go to the entrance instead?
Do I want to learn the controls? No no! I'm okay! I'm okay! Maybe!
We're gonna just yell away!
Do I press A?
Oh.
Hello.
My name is...
Hello?
Hello.
My name is...
is MercyModee...
I'm here to see your boss
It's dangerous...
My friends are all dead
Your voice is a kid you do not look like a kid!
Looks like what?
i'm floating
oh shit
what do you mean there's more than 14?
dan smith
oky dokey
huh?
Can I talk to him now?
Or is this just a tutorial again?
Master!
Okay, a real tight spot, right in a real tight spot, yeah, yeah, yeah, like I haven't seen
you for ages.
Where are you see through?
It is I, Vincil Dill Boris Will.
It was out of school at your service, just call me, it was out of, okay, okay, let me
show you along the way to the right master's room, okay, straight ahead the enemy.
Let the bloodbath begin in the name of Harman, who the heck is Harman?
I think something's coming towards me, what the hell?
Oh, wait, I had to scan first, that's fine, that's fine, we got this, we got this, we
got this.
Master, yes, yes, yes, we're in a tight spot, yeah, I know, tight and out of sight.
Let me make a suggestion, uh-huh, uh-huh.
We must turn back, this is the enemy's den, shudder to think their bodies are lined with
bombs, bombs, they'll bomb rush you, literally, eliminate them before they blow, in the name
of Harman, they're wearing bombs, oh shit, oh sorry, whatever, I don't remember anything,
your chief killed me, funky, okay, funky man, you already forgot, yeah, I forgot, I'm
Travis, Travis, touchdown, I'm the killer who got killed on the job, let's be totally
honest here, you think I'm a pain in the ass, don't you, hey Smith, I ain't letting you
go nowhere, I don't want to kill you, but I will, what the fuck, hold on, am I, am I,
can I, can I, no, your shoes, your pants, your arms, fuck this shit, well fuck, he's
a ghost, what do you mean he's a ghost, you mean he's a ghost and a bitch, he's a ghost,
fuck it, I'm gonna practice more, what, chat, somebody's hanging around, I don't like it,
I mean, I mean, somebody's hanging around, can you get that for me, fine, he was out
secrets, master, we're in a tight spot, okay, okay, that guy is a true freak, yeah, yeah,
but don't be alarmed, he's my trusted companion, Kikazaru, those things that master seek, the
bullets, he loves them so, the bullets were left behind by masters, so the servants searched
for them tirelessly, bullets of the soul, otherwise known as soul shells, in the name
of Harman, wait, do I have limited bullets, bullets, okay, here we go,
where the fuck, I can't fucking see shit,
I didn't have to do anything, yeah!
Where's my son, there you go, I'm gonna call you my son now, I have adopted you, you are
mine, okay, we are in a tight spot, this mayhem is out of control, our members have a thirst
for terror, with the helion use the R button and press the Y button three times, wait what,
when the test tube fills up with blood, you can fire a deadly shot, the devil's bullet,
he can only fire with enough blood, it's the right button and Y three times, in the name of
Harman, okay, let's turn back now, so do I go here, one, wait, one two three, one two three,
one two three, one two three, I can't fucking see, did I flip the other way, yeah, yeah, yeah,
okay, I can't, I forgot, it was this one and then we scan right, like this,
so life personality and press the A button,
what, what, what, what, personality changes, wild, okay fuck it,
I'm just, what, where is he, he's seen a little scramble, he's dead now, you have to pick a new
character, what, wait so I only have, I only have six lives, seven lives, sorry,
so that's bad because I am an idiot, I am an idiot, there's a lot of controls right now,
it's pretty dope, actually yeah this is pretty dope, I just, I'm just kind of stupid, I'm kind of
stupid, there's a lot of things I have to remember, okay, I'm slowly getting it, do not safe, I'm sorry,
Senpai, I'm sorry Senpai, I'm very bad at games, it's a crazy game and it has a crazy learning
curve, okay, okay, okay, I should save, okay, it's a little, it's a little tough, I admit, it's a
little tough, the Samantha just, what do I do with the TV, oh, okay, I see it, I understand,
okay so that's where I change the personalities, we're learning together,
what's that do, now you give,
now you give me the, the, the instructions and the words, okay, okay, okay, Senpai you're
gonna study with me, okay, you're gonna study with me right now, there's the info dump, master,
we're in a tight spot, I know, I know what you're hanging, it's the button arrangement,
run with the A button, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, turn around with the B button, high, high, high, high,
press the B button while running to turn quick, a little practice travel will be a breeze,
I pray for your speedy mastery, the name of Haruma,
okay, I don't want to study, it's okay, we're gonna study together, this is how we learn things,
junctions, what is junctions, master, we're in a tight spot, you need a sense of direction,
have you got used to the junctions, here's how to read them, junctions that you've already passed turn
blue, junctions that you have not passed are clear, if you get confused, follow the gray to come back,
the name of Haruma, okay, okay,
did he just, I feel like I got called out for a second senpai, where, where,
where, where my little gimp son has told me that I am, I have a bad sense of direction,
vitalities, okay, master, we're in a tight spot, I just, I can just sense it, look at those eyes,
eyes that see right through you, as they close, the member weakens,
when they shut completely, the member dies, you must continue to feed it blood, oh we're gonna
feed blood to our member, huh, you can use a test tube, when the eyes turn red, keep an eye on them,
the name of Haruma, okay, okay, we're going through this,
we're in a tight spot, you need to learn the basics, oh shut up, I mean, okay,
press the start pause to open the sub menu, you can select from four categories,
select that, with the control stick and the A button, move up to change personas, okay,
select a persona and he says she will appear, if you want to select sleeping persona,
wake him plus her up using the T in the name of Haruma, okay, okay, persona mentioned,
persona, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, baby, master, we're in a tight spot, standard stuff really,
press the start slash pause to open the sub menu, select with control stick and the A button,
toggle right to view more pigeon notes, read the letters brought by pigeons,
toggle left to equip accessories, please select a ring master, other objects will unlock the future,
if a ring is returned, remember to equip it, the name of Haruma, okay, okay,
give us a second, so we press start,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
what is the start button, is it this button, no,
Azura, oh thank you Azura for the raid, Azura, Azura, Azura, Azura,
Da, da, da, da, da, da, assou da da da.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sorry, sempai's, assou da.
Okay, Xbox controller should be the ones
with the two squares on it.
Well, it says return to title screen.
Do I have to do it while in this screen instead?
Or maybe I just don't have items yet.
Whatever.
But welcome everyone.
I'm just having trouble with controls right now.
So I'm doing a little bit of studying.
A little bit of studying
because this game's a little bit funky,
but we'll get it, we'll get it.
I mean, I, admittedly, the games I played,
two to 51 games I played, Killer is Dead.
I thought I played Killer Seven at first,
but it turns out I was playing Killer is Dead instead.
I need a rhyme.
And I played The Silver Case.
I've also played, what's the sequel to The Silver Case?
That one.
And I think that's it.
I think that's it.
All I played of two to 51 games.
So those are the games that I've played.
I'm not very familiar with this type of gameplay.
I'm very bad at shooty games
because I've never played shooting a game before as well.
Did you understand The Silver Case?
I really liked The Silver Case the most.
I went through all 100 endings of the sequel.
What was it called again?
The 25th Ward.
Yeah.
It was great.
So I like that game, but it was more of a,
it was more of a, what do you call it?
More of a visual novel in my opinion.
It was more of a visual novel, a little bit of walking.
So I think that was fine.
So I did all the endings and then all I got was,
oh no, should I?
Oh no, that's a spoiler, right?
That's a spoiler, right?
I don't know if I can spoil it.
Yeah, I'm not gonna spoil it.
Mm.
Was it disappointing?
You can spoil it?
Mm, okay, okay.
Well, it's only because Senpai said that I can spoil it.
Well, all you have to get is Kamali telling you,
asking you for a loan.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha, ha ha ha, ha ha ha.
Getting us into the multi-level marketing, the MLM.
Project.
What was it?
Can I have a loan of like 50,000 and or something?
Ha ha ha ha ha ha.
Anyways, yeah, basically trying to convince us to go
into their little MLM project, eh?
Ha ha ha ha ha.
2 to 51 likes to mock player 200% in his games
and I did 100% it.
Yeah, I really did.
Give me a loan, the end, pretty much.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha, it was fun though, it was fun.
I don't regret it.
I don't regret it, but definitely,
I know what I'm getting into,
it's just that I gotta get used to the game play.
Mm, mm, mm, mm, mm.
Speaking of MLMs, have you guys, have my Senpais.
Ooh, okay, we're in a tight spot, sorry.
You mustn't get lost.
If you do, use the X button.
Mm, mm, mm, mm, okay.
Go open a map, collect all the soul shells, get lost,
follow the icon, in the name of Harman.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay.
Continuing that story, sorry about that.
I acted, my fingies clicked faster than I could.
Oh, just give me a second.
I'm gonna just close this window.
Sistracting.
Ha ha ha, excuse me.
Let me just, have you guys ever,
have my Senpais ever gotten tricked into,
into like going to a pyramid scheme party before?
Ha ha ha, because I have,
ha ha ha ha, I have an old friend from high school
was like, we love to meet up again.
And I said, yeah, sure.
Then I thought about it for a second.
I said, it's not a pyramid scheme, is it?
They assured me, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
It's not a, it's not a pyramid scheme.
Just come over and we'll hang out, like good old times.
I said, okay.
So I drive all the way there.
All the way to there, in the middle of nowhere.
Ha ha ha.
I thought I was gonna die.
Because it was so far away, there were no lights
or anything, I was really worried.
I was like, where the heck?
So I got to a very opulent mansion.
I'm sorry, I'm telling you guys,
I'm telling you my supplies of story.
Well, it doesn't matter,
you're stuck in the basement anyways.
Opulent mansion with like barely anything in it.
So I walk in and I meet her friends
who are showing off their opulent mansion
with their quote unquote
real medieval night suits, whatever it is, you know?
They have one, they said it's authentic.
I was like, it ain't authentic, brother.
It's not authentic, it was that shiny.
Yeah, they're like, it's a medieval, it's old, it's there.
And then I see this product around and then
I basically just said, look, just give me the whole fricking,
give me the whole fricking story right now.
I'm tired, please just give me the whole spiel right now.
So they sat me down and then they gave me the whole spiel
and then I said, that's nice, I'm gonna go eat now.
And I ate all the charcuterie board
and like the energy drinks and I brought them home with me
and then I left.
Great times.
It's really funny, they're like, it's not a pyramid scheme.
Hands me a literal pamphlet with a literal pyramid
on the pamphlet.
It's really funny, they're like,
it's not a pyramid scheme, hands me a literal pamphlet
with a literal pyramid on the pamphlet.
I left I left I was so I was so worried I was gonna get killed but then I was
like well you made me go through this entire you know video seminar thing of
your product I might as well get something out of it and basically I just
you know chow down good times
good times I was like yeah that's nice I'll think about it about the food though
you said there was food and then I left and then yeah I never heard from them
ever again I never heard from her ever again so that was that was something
sorry I'm so that's sick
no it's not my laugh it's not my laugh this is my regular laugh I was sick
yesterday I didn't want to worry anyone yesterday but before stream I was
really worried I had to cancel because when I said okay well I feel a little
funky so I'm gonna go I had to do an idol meeting and I say I was doing my
idol meeting I felt something in my throat and then I went I threw up I
threw up and then I was so worried I had to cancel stream I didn't want to
cancel stream so I I quickly I got a little baggy baggy just in case anything
happens I wanted to to really meet my senpai's but then I ended up being so
flimmy
I honestly I'm probably really I'm actually still really nervous I guess
you guys my senpai can hear in my voice I'm still really nervous talking with
everyone so I'm probably yeah I got really sick before stream and so I
really toughed it out the entire time
what if you threw up on us and want to sleep oh I don't want to really throw up
on you on my senpai's because then now I have to clean it up so yeah I didn't
want any I want to miss out the 2.0 the 2.0 sorry so yeah so I'm just yeah
oh let's continue yay
master we're in a tight spot a very tight spot master members of the syndicate
are under your command the wasn't and that's simple multiple personalities the
perfect research subject multiple personalities but with multiple bodies
your very own monopolized field ever Garcin cannot change personality at
will he must use the TV oh that's why the start didn't work and watch for the
security camera the name of Harman okay that's why it didn't work
okay that that makes sense why it didn't work I was like well you gave me the
instructions for this
okay remnant psychs psyche okay master we're in a tight spot
patriot abounds the transparent bodies that haunt you are remnant psychs
psychs or psychies I can't read they refuse to let go of their attachment to
this world why is this happening you ask you should know I'm master because you
killed them but then there are those who would rather be dead and so thank you
like myself wait while you're dead my son is dead in the name of Harman
psychies jokes aside anything we can do to help ease the nervousness just be
super understanding if that's okay he's dead he's literally hanging I thought he
was just hanging around you know like a like a like a silly little guy you know
maybe he's he's on like one of those one of those trampoline thingies that make
you fly and then he just flies around
that's what I thought
bungee cord yeah I thought he was just on that
you know I thought he was just hanging around like that he was just like we
following us around on some kind of little rail a little
did I kill my son that's sad I maybe there's like tons of rails you know tons
of rails everywhere and just being followed like master we're in a tight
spot
this happens to be everywhere you know it's that maid Samantha when she dressed
formally she's all work and no play she's a reliable save maid okay okay use
the seven saves but beware when she's in her street clothes she's a terror an
out-of-control net surfer the room with the red lamp indicates formal attire the
room with the green lamp her casual garb in the name of Harman wait I can't save
when she's wearing regular clothes
is she like a v-teeber gatekeeper master we're in a tight spot it's a world of
sin have you met the center he's the keeper of the vinculum gate the guide
to the other world if you collect socials to let you buy why you want to do
that I don't know in the name of Harman so I killed my son okay I can't believe
I'm getting plot I'm getting plot through the info jumping
master we're in a tight spot this is gonna be a crazy battle enemies are
invisible in fact they don't even exist you hear if you hear laughter quickly
press the R button this was this will ready your weapon but this still won't
reveal them use the L button and the chief will scan their skill when they
take on physical form fire away with the a button destroy them in the name of
Harman I if they could have just told me that they could have just told me that
that was so confusing in the tutorial I could have saved on the tutorial let's
see sorry I didn't miss your two point all had no choice but to touch grass nice
to be able to catch you live finally yeah thank you thank you sound five we're
dining in the tutorial is funky yeah it's super funky I didn't get it okay so I'm
gonna I'm gonna continue this that's the joke this is the real tutorial this is
the real tutorial oh my goodness Senpai Senpai hold me please
hold my hand as we go through this together had to die once to get a
proper tutorial master we're in a tight spot this job to get a little crazy you'll
have to polish your skills there's no time to aim carefully after the scan use
the B button your instinct will allow you to aim for nearby button press the
control pad to aim the next enemy in the name of Harman okay unprotected as a
treat as a treat okay what's this one master we're in a tight spot don't tell
them I told you but the enemies have a weakness once focused hits and even a
great dragon tumbles to his death those strange gold particles it can only be
seen when you're aiming the gun take my advice go for gold the name of Harman oh
okay recovery master granite tight spot you've got to watch your damage test
start pause to open the submenu select the category with the control stick in
the A button blood is at the bottom press the A button to revive figure your
personas will be up in Adam use the blood in the test tubes when the eyes
begin to close your persona is in a tight spot use the test tubes immediately in
the name of Harman body retrieval oh my gosh we literally have to go through
everything
master we're in a tight spot a real tight spot their bombs are absolutely deadly
yeah I figured that out I don't even take out our personas if a persona die
leave it to Garcian you may be a big oaf but he's a master cleaner yes there's a
job for everyone oh and don't forget after he cleans up reanimate the persona
from the paper bag rapidly press the A button to revive in the name of Harman
they did this on purpose oh Suda did this on purpose he made me die on purpose
getting so confused about the tutorial to get to the real tutorial that's so rude
master we're in a tight spot the skill is extraordinary the hellion Dan loves
destruction he's bound to destroy the enemy's nest just the Y button three
times while holding the gun with the R button three test tubes will be equipped
use the A button to launch a demon shell red and yellow cores indicate the
next week's point in the name of Harman
Kaede's special attacks
master we're in a tight spot the skill is extraordinary barefooted Kaede as a
real thing for sniping pretty scary if you ask me use the Y button while
standing ready with the R button you'll switch to a sculpt view allowing you to
hit long-ranged creeds in the name of Harman
okay why an R that might be a little hard to remember these I hope I hope
Senpai's don't mind that I'm going through all of this
master we're in a tight spot not really that tight let me explain how blood
works the blood in the beaker is pure give blood to the doctor inside the TV
the doctor may look a bit off but he's a true gentleman he won't do you wrong
prepare blood serums for you use them to give personas a heightened consciousness
level up this allows a member to achieve special attacks in the name of Harman
all right
all right all right blood absorption master we're in a tight spot this blood
is scary stuff but without blood there is no tomorrow the persona can absorb the
blood out of the enemy and acts as a stabilizer to help handle multiple
personalities without blood your very life is in danger press start slash pause
to check the blood form you must use blood wisely in the name of Harman awakening
master we're in a tight spot there's no way to put it there's no other way to
put it your personas killer seven are not in step yes start slash pause check
the condition of each persona and only use those in good shape restore
condition by taking out the enemy if you exterminate enough you can wake up
personas that you didn't murder makes the blood boil enter the TV to wake them
up the name of Harman right about special abilities I'll probably just read
Garcians first and then we'll skip kaii days maybe master we're in a tight spot
and I know a really tight secret our members have loads of skills the wide
button control skills I'll help you with each skill in the name of Harman
master we're in a tight spot the skill is out of control the chief has a strange
skill use the power of the ring to see through all the al button scans no doubt
the name of Harman okay I think these are closed eyes wait wait wait we're in a
tight spot real tight spot like I haven't seen you for ages I okay even so
Dilbertus it was a rough cough you can call me it was out okay okay okay I got
it I mean I mean means I read it already
how much tighter can this bucket so tight really tight so tight you'll be like please
stop master this is too much quite a laugh really these enemies are more than
just bomb freaks rumor has it they're altering human beings if you just think
they're gonna attack head-on you'll get burned you can expect a delivery of new
types in the near future don't be fooled by their cackling aim straight for their
weak points in the name of Harman
Emilia master we're in a tight spot it's between you and me there's a traitor
amongst the enemy wants to defend the fact to your side his body is stark white
but staying with blood since he was baptized for being a traitor the poor
creeps they tell your personas where to use the skills press the Y button to use
it but just between you and me in the name of Harman
micro master granite spot just between you and me there's a delivery man amongst
them delivery man I recognize that they need him to resupply the nest the
delivery truck is small it's designed to go undetected but it's stocked full of
supplies so if you can take it out the benefits will be okay that's a lot black
and yellow full recovery of the syndicates how red and blue large blood
infusion delivery truck attacks don't do damage it what a temporarily affect
your vision don't let this target slip by wait wait wait the name of harm wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait there's a truck that attacks me there's a truck
that attacks me master this is too much strategic city egg duplicator is a nest
the month the mini egg layers that was too fast and vantages of the region the
cores are the weak points yellow cores are easily destroyed but for the red
cores use hellions demon shells the name of Harman I have to see that again
sorry sorry sorry senpai I have to read this again okay is the nest the egg
players are building a base the advantage of the region okay they were
building a base okay okay the name Harman it's Harman guys okay I'm just
lost okay I think that's good enough
that's a place I've gone before blue is where I've gone before
I want the hallway yes I haven't been there oh that's the entrance okay let's
turn around and we'll go back to the hallway all the gray to go back
I talked to Travis again it's me you don't remember your chief killed me you
already forgot I'm Travis I'm the killer who got killed on the job let's talk
let's be totally honest here you think I'm gonna pay in the ass don't you hey
Smith I ain't letting you go nowhere all right okay let's see if I can do this
there it goes now
wait sorry
I heard a laugh, so I figured there should be someone.
I did it!
Okay, what was the instructions again?
Do I click him, tap A?
Oh, I can resurrect him.
Press the R button rapidly.
Oh, A button, never mind. That's not A.
Sorry, I thought that was R.
Alright!
Sorry, it looked like an R.
Should I select Dan again?
Maybe I should use him again.
Yeah, let's use him again.
Alright.
Yeah?
Okay, there it is.
Hallway, understood.
What are you drinking, Kohai?
Um, tea.
I think it's a peppermint tea.
Okay, now I can probably do Dan better.
That was so rude.
Okay, we game in!
Okay.
Ah!
I got it!
Okay.
Understood.
Ah!
Oh!
Oops!
Shit!
Ow!
Ah!
I think I'm too close!
Ah, I was too close!
Ah!
I was too close!
I was too s-
Sorry!
Sorry, Garcian!
I'm gonna have to use your services again.
Sorry!
Oops!
You got better, though!
Yeah, I'm getting better!
Just a little bit.
I'm trying to kinda still understand the mechanics.
It's a little tough, but I think I got quite a bit of it.
Ah!
Look, I'm a cleaner.
I can feel no remorse for seeing that.
Ah!
Yeah, you gotta keep my distance with those eggs.
This time real.
Probably.
I'm a little confused about how to do the...
the special move again.
I know it's R and then hitting the Y button three times, right?
Do I smash?
I'll try my best.
Whatever.
When it comes, it comes.
Okay.
I'm bad.
Ah!
Not again!
This is too easy.
They crawl so fast!
Ah!
This is too easy.
Wait, where's the weakness?
A little shot.
You guys are so close!
I understand!
I understand it!
This is just a duplicator.
Bad girl!
An egg laying heaven smile.
Refitted to clamp down on the city.
This sucker pumped out the countless duplicates
that took this country down.
Hey, Smith.
It's your job to eradicate heaven smile, right?
And seek the queen.
The gatekeeper is in charge of the queen.
Give this to the gatekeeper.
He won't be disappointed.
Is that Pizza Hut?
Is that the Pizza Hut love?
Pull it.
Received Soul Shell.
Okay.
Is that Pizza Hut logo?
Yeah.
I did it!
Are you guys, are my supplies proud of me?
Can I get a head pat?
Okay, I did it.
I feel a little happy that I did it.
I guess I have to just go back now.
Yay, thank you, some pies.
Huh?
Did I go this way?
Oh!
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Wait.
Oh my gosh!
My little gimp son spooked me for a second!
Master, we're in a tight spot.
An ultra tight spot.
Life is precious.
And the enemies mean business.
They're called heaven smile.
Look at their eyes.
There's nothing heavenly about them.
In the name of Harmon.
Wait, maybe I should go back.
Maybe I should go back and save?
What do you think?
Maybe I should go back to the save.
Yeah.
Since I'm very new, I just beat that little...
Okay.
Harmon's room?
Is that the one I need to go to?
Yes.
Samantha.
Okay.
Let's overwrite this one.
Yes.
We're good.
Okay, we're good now.
How's your head feeling so far, Mercy?
I think it's okay.
Okay.
I don't know if this game is...
What do you call it?
Um...
If it would be like a game that
a major company would fund nowadays.
But it seems really cool.
Once you get used to it, I think
once you get used to the controls, it takes a while, but I get it.
Huh?
Ah!
Hey, I'm not...
Okay.
Any motherfuckers?
Any other motherfuckers here?
Thank you.
Oh!
Oh my God!
I could have just saved up here?
Wow!
Jeez, are you...
She's scared.
This is the...
This is the scary, right?
This is the scary one, right?
Is she gonna attack me?
Do I talk to her?
Should I talk to her?
Okay, well, I'll talk to her.
Never mind.
I'm just gonna go to the telly.
Who the hell is this?
I've changed my makeup.
Did you notice?
What did you say?
Later.
Oh, they're all Smith!
I just realized they're all Smith.
Okay, we're slowly unlocking them.
Understood.
No, okay.
Is there anything else she has in here?
No?
Can I talk to her?
Or is she just gonna...
Is she just gonna just, like, stare at me like that?
Oh, shit.
No!
Okay.
I had a moment.
I'm sorry.
I forgot how the game worked.
I forgot how it worked.
What the heck is that?
I nearly fucking died!
Ah!
What the fuck?
I'm lost now.
I got lost.
That was a truck!
X to pull up map.
Where am I?
Holy shit, Travis scared me again!
Ah!
Let's talk serious for a second.
Heaven's smile, they're holy warriors.
Shit, ain't that pretty wicked?
Warriors who fight with the holy will on their side
and use death as a weapon.
Their target?
The very dignity of the country itself.
Well, why should you understand the meaning?
Shit, you're a killer after all.
Oh my gosh, he just fucking scared me!
I guess this means...
Is green a color I didn't know?
Hahahaha!
Come on.
You gotta help me.
Ah!
Bean.
Oh!
Who are you?
Oh, like old times, huh?
Tell me how's old Smith?
Things going good with Mills, no?
That old Smith, not much of a successor.
But good man, yes.
Thank you, much gratitude.
Ready for today's hint?
I checked the candlesticks.
A strange design indeed is...
It is hidden there.
The order is hidden here.
Want to know more?
Then use this mask.
I'll be right back.
Want to know more?
Then use this mask.
Shoot the mask, and the mask will tell you.
But watch out!
This mask's lust for blood.
Thicker blood.
Demon lust for blood, yes?
If you're brave, shoot the mask.
Shoot the mask.
It'll tell you everything.
Am I close to a save point?
Hold on.
Where am I exactly?
You're...
You're in the yellow by the hand icon.
This map's hard to read.
You're next to the hand and ring symbol, I think.
Okay.
How much further is the save?
I'm facing south, okay.
Yeah, I have to...
I have seen more useful maps in games, I admit.
Yeah, that's kinda hard.
So...
Okay, I'll shoot it.
It's not gonna come attack me, right?
Is it gonna attack me?
Okay.
I've beaten this game a million times.
I'm so glad I have, I have senpai's,
seasoned senpai's for this game,
because I am a little bit confuzzled at times.
Okay.
So how do I shoot the mask?
Just aim like normal, okay.
Okay.
With your gun, okay.
I know with my gun, but I'm like, do I...
Like...
Like this?
Wait.
Did he just...
Did he just give me the middle finger?
So, you are the worthless loser.
What a pitiful existence.
I am the true mask.
And I shall guide you.
The ring of fire
and number shown on the candlestick.
From one to five,
follow the order and ignite the flames.
Tomorrow, it could be you.
Son of a bitch,
he's just given me the middle finger.
This one?
Insufficient flame.
Eh?
I didn't even know there was a room there!
Shit.
Sorry.
At a moment.
Oops.
Sorry.
Please help me.
It suddenly disappeared.
A white light flashed before me.
Everything is transparent.
I held his hand.
Whose hand was it?
Then, before I knew it, I was lost again.
Please help me.
I can't see a thing.
I don't think I finished exploring here.
What the fuck happened?
Oops.
What happened?
Wait, was that the woman I saw before? Never mind.
I know what happened.
I don't remember which way I went.
It's locked from the other side.
Okay.
Power.
What was that?
Did I go to here already?
I feel like I've already been here.
Yeah, you have.
I've been here already.
Okay.
Wow, I'm silly, Billy.
What's that?
Did I go to here already?
I feel like I've already been here.
Yeah, you have.
I've been here already.
Okay.
Wow, I'm silly, Billy.
I got really confused.
Sorry.
Oh, right.
Travis was here.
My bad.
That was the wrong way.
Okay.
I'm starting to get it.
Bro!
Master!
We're in a tight spot.
A major tight spot.
He's here.
Yes, him!
Master, you can't.
You're going to go and kill him?
What?
Impossible.
You're a fool.
And you're a go-
You can't read.
Impossible. You're sure to fail.
You know nothing of his strength.
All stupid, stupid master.
That mill's really fooled you.
In the name of the fool.
Should I...
Do I have flames?
Does do...
Hahaha.
Nobody has faith in me.
It's fine.
I don't even have faith in myself.
This way?
Oh, carry your pigeon.
Give me the pigeon.
Dear Amir.
It is a pleasure to make your acquaintance
and many thanks for choosing me for the job.
My name is Johnny Gagnan.
Otherwise known as
Speedster.
Okay.
I get excited when I slit a guy's throat.
I know that may be sick,
but I do the best work in town.
This is a report on the job.
I'm sure you'll like what I have to say.
I watch them like a hawk.
So I think a hefty reward is an order.
There are seven in the Smith's Indian.
Dear Smith.
Who uses a large caliber revolver?
Hi, Dace.
No, not dear.
Dan Smith.
Wow.
Gagnan, these nuts.
Shut up!
Hahaha.
Feeling a little too relatable to the text?
Maybe a little bit.
Who uses a large automatic rifle?
Okay.
Hi, Dace Smith.
Who uses a large automatic rifle?
Colin Smith.
Who uses two full auto pistols?
Masked a Smith.
Who uses grenades?
Kevin Smith.
Who uses knives?
What are these names?
Coyote Smith.
Who uses a modified gun?
Christian Smith. Who uses a small pistol?
They are an armed force
that rivals a small army.
You wouldn't want to be on their bad side.
In conclusion, it is in
the interest of the United States
to keep them around.
There's no telling when they might come in handy.
Meet the Smiths.
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
I'll be contacting you again.
Johnny Gagnan.
Oh!
Obtained career memo.
I guess I got to turn back then.
Can I save now?
Maybe not?
I want to see the telly.
Don't make me say it again.
Wait here.
I've changed my makeup.
Did you notice?
Kevin!
What did you say?
Later.
Peace.
Masked a Smith.
I can wake them up.
Can I wake them up, guys?
Is it in my best interest
to wake them up?
Don't make me say it again.
Wait here.
I've changed my makeup.
What did you say?
Later.
Masked a Smith.
Oh!
He's really wearing a luchador mask.
Wow.
Later.
What about this one? Can I wake this one up?
Kevin, you're a little bit gangly.
Why are you so tall?
Is Kevin any good?
He's so...
He's so gangly.
Later.
Peace.
Destiny.
Did he just say destiny?
There's 11 channels. Does that mean I have?
Don't make me say it again.
Wait here.
I've changed my makeup.
What did you say?
Later.
Destiny.
That's all he said. It was just destiny.
Are you sure you'll be calling anyone gangly?
I have the right to insult anyone.
Also, it's Killer7, but there's
11 channels.
Great serum from Blood by pressing
the A button.
Select Personality
and press the A button.
Wait here.
I've changed my makeup. Did you know?
What did you say?
Later.
Peace.
Who should I go?
What did you say?
Later.
Should there be someone I choose for now?
I'm letting my senpais
backseat me right now.
What did you say?
I've changed my makeup.
Destiny.
We'll use
Mask.
I just like
teleported in.
I
have such bad posture.
What happened?
Why did it scan?
I'm so sorry.
I don't understand why it didn't scan.
I
What the?
Why didn't it scan?
At that time.
No, no, no.
I pressed the...
Maybe I didn't hold it down enough.
That was my bad.
What the hell?
I
Oh my gosh.
I'm hitting back.
I gotta use
Mask
this way.
He's so slow.
Wait, I can change right here?
How do I change right here?
I
What button?
Oh, I found it.
Should I use consmith then?
How do I heal from the screen?
I have...
Okay, there's some stuff.
I have any items?
Photos.
Who the heck is this?
You know, he kind of looks like
what's his name? The gumshoe guy
from Ace Attorney.
I just...
wall?
Blood?
Oh.
Okay, I understand.
I guess I can try.
Hi, Dave.
Whoa! You didn't fucking kill him!
You didn't fucking kill him?
I feel like I just fucking killed him.
Wait, did I just
upskirt her? Hold on.
If I'm going to use Kaede,
I have to read about her.
Hold on.
Oops.
We're in a tight spot, yeah, yeah.
Sorry, sorry about
breaking Senpai's ears.
I know, it rattles
the cage a little.
Okay.
Sorry, I meant
to go down to Kaede's
in the night. I had
my little quick thingies.
Master!
We're in a tight spot.
The skill is extraordinary.
Barefoot can call
spirit Mizaru.
You can break barriers.
Allowing you to
explore new areas.
You can also
Press the Y button to use it.
In the name of her, Ma.
Wait.
Don't make me say it again.
Wait here.
I changed my makeup.
What did you say?
Coyote Smith.
Are you super fast?
Are you super slow?
The skill is extraordinary.
If you press 1, 3, 6,
you can play a swaps personality.
I'm using a controller.
I'll check.
I'll use it for now.
Why is he holding it upside down?
Not!
Why did you aim down there?
why did you aim down there there was a there was a there was a gold there is
gold it might take a little while to get used to
the each character hello
oh it's me I sell information but it's not so simple no I checked the toilet
hmm it fills with water and it goes well with the sprinkler how can I make it
spray shoot the mask to hear more yeah no no no you you you flipped me off last
time you flipped me off last time I remember that
haha oh gosh there's a guy I'm using the bathroom can you be freaking polite
huh excuse in the bathroom geez what the heck is this
well it has no water
sprinkler
do I need the flame thing the flame the flame the flame and then if I can use
the flame I can I can use it I don't have the ring though I don't have the
ring I don't have the fire
oh sorry I meant to use this one not that one
where do I get the flame
hmm library
I don't have, I don't have an item for this yet.
Alright!
Oh?
Okay, she's back to normal, I can save now!
Woo! Save, save, save, save, save!
Oh hey, I didn't realize!
Okay, okay, okay, okay.
We're gucci, probably.
Ooh.
Can I unlock anyone else now?
Don't make me say a cheese.
I've changed my makeup.
I've changed my-
Cheese.
I've changed-
What did you say?
Later.
Destiny.
Why is he bouncing like that?!
Ooh.
I guess I-
How'd I turn my blood to the doctor?
Oh!
Is that all he's used for?
How'd I level up?
I have to go in the hallway for this?
Ooh!
Ooh.
Okay, upgrade the TV.
Okay, thank you, senpai!
You're helping me so much!
In exchange, I'll let you have five minutes of free time in the cage.
Don't make me say it again.
I'm a cleaner.
Wait here.
Power.
Hmm.
What should I put on for Dan?
What's waiver?
Waiver helps with aim?
Okay.
Maybe I'll put someone's aim since I'm bad at it!
Waiver velvet from fate?
Hmm.
Oh wait, what is the waiver from fate?
I have enough for more, should I put in more?
I've changed my makeup.
What did you say?
Later.
Pee.
Destiny.
Spend as much as you want, you can farm easily, okay.
Okay!
Decisions, decisions.
Don't make me say it again.
I'm a cleaner.
Does Garcian have no level up thingies?
Yeah, whatever, we'll level Dan up a little, but I'm kind of used to him.
Oh wait, I should probably save.
I'm so silly.
What a silly Billy I am.
Save!
Samantha, please be kind to me, I'm gonna save!
Okay, health looks good.
Uh, these stairs?
An object.
Grier?
Eh?
Well hello, Smith.
Looks like a cloudy, cloudy day!
What is really too bad, sad face?
Uh, day to hang out in the laundry.
Great day to use a dryer though.
But you know, I just love this one.
I'll never let anybody have it.
You know why?
Well you should.
I love to stay inside.
You left this behind, didn't you?
I got it!
I got it, I got the firing!
If you finish your business, could you hurry up and leave?
You're very much in the way.
Assassins should have better manners.
Okay, thank you.
And then I go here, items.
Like that, right?
Should I head back now?
Should I save?
I'll save again.
Sorry, I'm saving all the time so I don't forget.
Wait, should I turn the dryer back on for her?
Maybe I should.
Oh my gosh, I'm such a rude, I'm such a rude friend.
I forgot to turn it off!
Never mind, I'm leaving.
Where the fuck did that come from?
Whatever, luckily I saved.
What the fuck?
Hey, my bitches!
Now what?
What was that?
What the fuck?
What fell?
Where did it fall?
Laundry, okay, we're heading back to the laundry.
What is that?
Odd engraving.
Wait, now that I have this, should I backtrack to the candles?
What the fuck?
It's an odd engraving.
Yeah, we should do the backtrack.
Man, what a pain!
Ha ha ha!
What was that sound?
My map?
I'm just gonna take the stairs.
Ha ha ha!
Okay, I didn't backtrack too far.
Handle.
Air conditioning?
Oh, come on.
One, two, three, four, five.
Oh!
What's air conditioner?
Did I need it on or off?
Oh.
Oh!
But I don't need it anymore, right?
Ha ha ha!
Wait, which way?
Oh.
He's still flipping you off, like a bitch.
I mean, he should.
I'm not that great of a person.
Go back, you forgot the puzzle piece.
Huh?
Dogo?
What shelf? The one in the room?
Oh, wow!
Odd engraving.
Ha ha ha!
Look at how much of a pro I am now.
I improved so much, Senpai.
Oh.
Oh, there's so many of you.
Ah!
Can I do this control panel?
Oh!
Sorry, your leg.
Man!
That was kind of brutal.
Warehouse.
Oh?
Oh my gosh!
It was out of you, you scared me again!
Master!
We're in a tight spot.
Mask is for your disc-
Gizli rack.
When there's a crack, it's his shul.
He's filthy powerful.
No destroy, all of kingdom come.
And then some.
He's a liability if you ask me.
In the name of Harman.
Oh!
I get it.
I'm picking up while you're putting down game.
I change.
Mask here.
I get it.
I'm so, yeah.
Now what?
I just...
Wait, but like now what?
Oh!
What the hell is that?
Carry a pigeon.
Dear Amir.
We have a problem.
A terrible thing has happened. Pussy!
My pigeon's name is Pussy!
Pigeonosee?
Who named this?
Anyways.
Who named these pigeons?
Dear Amir. Amir, we have a problem.
A terrible thing has happened.
I can hardly believe it.
But the money is not in my account.
What the fuck do you mean?
I need your help. You got my last messages, didn't you?
I trusted you.
Now don't let me down. Promise me.
Wire me the money immediately.
125 bucks is peanuts, I'm telling you.
Smith's syndicate operates in strange ways.
Garcia and Smith manages the other six personas
and mainly acts as a negotiator for work requests.
Garcia never eliminates people himself.
His role is to retrieve the bodies.
Even if another persona is killed,
it appears he is able to bring him back to life
like a wizard, I tell you.
However, it's my hunch that somebody offstage
is calling the shots and controlling Garcia.
There must be a hidden mastermind separate from the active team.
And it's likely that this mastermind assigns the jobs.
Garcia is very loyal and he values the organization,
controls the personas to keep the organization safe.
He's a middle manager, you see.
A member switch using the medium of television.
I have yet to determine what governs the switches.
Wizard, Shadow Money, Wizard, Shadow, Wizard Money Gang?
Shadow, Shadow, Shadow, Shadow, Shadow Gang, Gang, Gang, Gang.
We love casting spells and sh**.
The Smith Syndicate is composed of one sensible person and six freaks.
I never seen the personas interact with each other.
Alright.
Soon, I expect to unmask the myth behind the strange group.
I'll be contacting you again, Johnny Guy, Gangman.
Tane, carry your memo.
Hold on, let me switch to someone else.
I like using Dan because he's kind of easier to use.
Oh!
Travis, what are you doing here?
I was the chief's first catch.
I can still remember.
The chief's quivering hand.
The pain went straight up my spine and then back down again.
Be honest, that should feel good.
It all happened on the smothering hot night.
Is that all you're gonna tell me, Travis?
Is that all you're gonna tell me?
Okay, I guess.
Oh.
Master, we're in a tight spot.
Like, tighter than tight.
Uh-oh.
Uh-oh?
Real?
Oh, I have offended my master with foul words,
but please, you must understand.
Just thinking about him drives me absolutely mad.
He fixes the sink to sink this country,
and so he's sending his unending blah-blah-blah
with no sign of letting up.
How many followers does he command?
Beware of old friends.
In the name of Harman.
Can I save?
Here.
Get my blood.
Take my blood doctor.
Blood doctor, blood doctor.
Take all my blood doctor.
Wait, I need the TV again, sorry.
Don't make me say it again.
I'm a cleaner.
Wait here.
I'm gonna...
improve my skills again.
Good enough.
Okay.
Now we get information here, right?
Get away!
What is this thing?
Why is it exploding?
Why does it explode like that?
This is too easy.
What?
Master, we're in a tight spot.
Watch out for barefoot.
Kaede.
I've sensed this presence before.
My ex-wife, Mizaru, was near.
What?
Is now the servant of barefoot.
Let my wife serve you through barefoot.
Use the Y button for a death shower.
In the name of Harman.
What a what?
What?
This is too easy.
Nice.
Wait, I went the wrong way.
I'm gonna go this way.
Death shower, he said.
What is death shower?
How'd I use her skill?
Gotta head out.
Good luck, Koi.
Goodbye!
Sorry, I'm very not paying attention to chat,
because I'm confused.
Confused.
What is this?
You don't need to aim for this one.
Just hit Y.
Oh.
Oh!
Let's grab this bullet.
Oh, I should probably change out.
Oh!
It's locked by padlock.
Guess I can't go there yet.
Not bad, me.
Oh, sorry.
I was like, oh my gosh!
Oh my gosh!
Hi, Travis.
Can you see it?
No, I can't see it.
Oh, sorry.
I was like, oh my gosh!
Hi, Travis.
Can you see it?
Words written in blood.
Obviously had a point to make.
But only two letters are written in real blood.
Rest are fake.
You need the girl for this one.
Does someone in my group pick locks?
I didn't pay attention.
What the hell is she doing with her hands?
Blood absorbed.
No, no what? No pussy? No head?
Well, I'll go back.
If I have someone, I'll just use them.
Oh!
Yay, blood! I think.
Travis? Huh? L.A.? Can't you see I'm busy?
You ought to mind your manners.
You guys are just a pack of losers.
You don't even know how to make use of your abilities.
There are traitors in heaven's smile.
The chief's very own inside guys.
They have a white body splattered with red paint.
A reminder of treacherous speed.
The girl!
Kite! Funny thing is the splotches look like beautiful red roses.
If you find a chameleon smile, use your ability.
Kill one of them and you'll get loaded up. For real, man.
Oh.
Important question. Are you having fun, Mercy? Yeah.
Oops.
Oopsies.
I'm going to switch out characters because I'm not used to them yet.
I'm getting tired. Kind of tired, though. Usually I have lots...
What?
Which way did I need to go again? I'm lost!
Can I go here already?
Oh, come on.
I got used to the game so now I feel more comfortable.
Can I save here?
Okay.
I want to just save here, guys.
And I'll probably end the gameplay here and I'll probably start yapping.
Probably start yapping.
That was a lot.
Ha ha ha ha!
Yeah, main outfit saves the day!
Oh!
Now, how do I get out of here?
Yes! Like this. I saved, right? I totally did.
Yatta!
Right, let's go...
Over here.
Okay.
How was it? How was it, Senpai? Did you like the game?
I finally... I think I got the hang of it.
It took a little bit, but I got the hang of it.
I was really shocked when...
At the beginning, the beginning was... Oh, hold on. Let me just fix myself a little bit. Let me...
Actually, maybe I kind of like myself looking like this, right?
There, I'm bright and beautiful again. You see me in all my glory.
Senpai!
You did like the game, though, right? After I chose it for you!
It's like the lights turned on.
It was really tough, but I managed to figure it out.
It only took up to now to actually fully get comfortable with the game.
It was pretty brutal, not going to lie to you.
At the beginning, the game...
I didn't get it.
That tutorial was pretty bad, and then I only got it when they gave me the info dump tutorial.
Then I was like, okay, I get it now, I get it now.
I'm on guard games are really fun, though.
I really like kind of experimental games, because I...
I find that kind of like, weirder gameplay...
makes me more interested in like, what the story's going to tell.
It was really, it was really...
The lore is even crazier, for real?
Okay, I can't wait to try this game again.
It might be a little bit, but we'll definitely pick this up again.
This entire week is booked up.
It's booked up, so we're going to explore a variety of games together.
Because...
Well, I just want to showcase each game that I play.
That I play for my supplies, where I strapped you...
Strapped you into a chair, just like in Clockwork Orange.
What was it? The Ludo something technique?
I forced your eyes open, and only...
And every once in a while, I put eye drops, so your eyes get moistered.
Ludovico technique, yeah!
I'm so glad my supplies are so smart!
This is why I love you so much.
Wow, my supplies are really smart!
You memorize that.
I'm so proud. Good job.
That movie was really fun.
It was really fun.
I'm hoping tomorrow... Let me check my schedule again.
I always forget what I scheduled.
Because I'm kind of clumsy.
My schedules are weeks in advance.
So I choose my games weeks in advance.
Let's see. Tomorrow is Omori.
In truth, I played Omori before.
I don't remember much of it.
I remember rage quitting, because I fought a bunch of bears.
It was like fighting a bunch of ICs at once.
It was brutal.
So that's where...
Imagine like 10 ICs coming at you.
Over and over and over and over again.
It takes you out of breath.
By the end of it, you're like,
Okay, I need to go heal up.
Then you come back.
They spawn back 10 more bears.
10 more ICs, okay?
So I rage quit at that part.
Now I learned my lesson.
I'm not going to do that this time.
Wait, Serenity's in chat?
Serenity, Serenity, Serenity!
My baby!
My baby bunny!
My bunny bunny, honey!
Honey!
I love you!
The bear fight was rough.
I found her.
I found her. Yes, it was.
It was. I cried.
I'm so happy you're here.
Oh, you're kind of up late.
I'm watching in bed. Have good sleeps then.
Have good sleeps then.
Tucks you in. Kisses you goodnight.
I'm so happy though.
Oh, I'm so, so happy.
Thank you Serenity for dropping by.
I love seeing you here all the time.
Thank you.
I'm sure my supplies love you too.
But yeah, don't try to steal my supplies away from me.
I will kill you.
Yeah, yeah!
Oh my gosh, I love you.
Yes, Senpai's got five minutes free time and out of the cage
until they go back again.
Serenity gets a basement visit permit or is she a resident?
Well, like she gets special privileges.
So like she's stuck in the basement, but she gets to go in and out freely.
Because I trust her.
Is our cage bedroom size?
It's dog cage size.
It's a little, it's a little um, a little cozy in there.
I put some star glow in the dark star stickers
or for my senpais to feel like they're looking up at the night sky.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
My senpais get a little doggy bed.
The plaid ones.
If you're, if you really get, if you're really feeling special.
Some, some days you get the velour one, the velour doggy bed.
With the little pillow and the stuffed animal.
That's every Fridays.
That's a treat.
As a treat. Yeah.
I'm so generous.
I know I treat, I'm, I'm such a good girlfriend.
I'm so happy though.
I'm such a good girlfriend.
I let you have all these wonderful treats.
In fact, I might give you a treat later.
Yeah.
Can we get McDonald's?
Everyone gets a happy meal.
Once a month.
The basement.
Everyone gets a happy meal.
Once a month.
You get a little toy to play with.
Can I have new clothes?
No.
Is that a little unhealthy at the McDonald's?
Well, it is a treat.
That's why it's a treat only once a month.
Yeah, everyone shares.
You got, everyone has to share.
Okay.
Everyone gets one little, little, little, little taste of the yogurt.
Everyone gets a tiny, tiny crumb of, of the fries.
And then have a little, little, little fight over the nuggets.
And the toy is shared amongst everyone.
Of course.
Can we not fight over it?
Well, if you, you're all good and willing to share,
you don't have to fight over it.
After all, it's a democracy here.
Kai won't be our toy?
Of course not.
You're my toy Senpai.
Can we vote for more time?
Yeah.
Democracy where, um,
Mercy's, Mercy's vote is worth 10 times more
than everyone else's combined.
I vote for last free time.
Oh.
Okay.
So last free time, that means you,
I can assign homework now.
Okay.
I can give Senpai's homework.
It's really easy.
It's really easy homework.
You'll love it.
Watch every single episode of Cardcaptor Sakura.
Come back with me with a thousand word,
a little essay about how you felt about it.
And then,
mostly your thousand word essay
must consist of why Sakura is the best
of about the movies.
They count.
It's just one long episode.
1,200 words?
Oh, you get bonus points then.
Your bonus point will be a little,
a little smooch.
A little smooch on your homework.
Can it be a group project instead?
No.
I can't call Sakura the best because you're the best.
Of course I'm the best.
But at the same time, we must,
if it wasn't for Sakura,
I wouldn't even be here.
Sakura actually,
got me through hard times.
The original, right?
Or will you do the Nirvana butchered version too?
Both.
When I said all episodes, I meant it in every single language.
Hahaha.
Instructions unclear.
Binge Chobits.
Oh, speaking of Chobits,
I just remember,
when I was a child,
I loved Chobits.
And I,
had no idea what Chobits was about.
So when you know,
little old,
baby Mercy went,
why is it such a big deal that,
there's a button there?
Of course there's a button there.
That's the last place I didn't look.
I had no idea.
Every time,
the entire time,
I was like, wow,
she is so cute.
I hope she's so happy with Hideki.
And then I watched it,
re-watched it again,
and I was like,
I shouldn't have watched this.
Why did I watch this?
I shouldn't have watched this
when I was a wee little lass.
I was,
yeah,
I didn't tell this one,
but I don't think it's a really cringe story,
but,
I guess there's a lot of things
when I didn't,
I was very ignorant of,
more so than now.
For example,
I used to call every single person,
who was like,
a female caretaker of me,
for example, like,
a mommy, right?
So I would call my teacher's mommy,
I would call,
I would call my friends,
my friends,
mom, mommy as well,
because I thought,
because I read in a book,
it says like,
oh, what is a mommy?
What is a mother?
A mommy is,
is someone who takes care of you.
So I just associated it
for a long time,
with just like,
just like any woman who took care of me.
And then I think,
I only found out when I got like,
really,
I got lectured about it,
by a teacher who did not,
like being called mommy.
He called friends,
now I called my friends,
mom,
this as well,
so I would call mommy,
their mommy, mommy.
Oh my gosh, Strony!
Strony calls.
Welcome,
mommy!
Mommy!
Speaking of mommies,
mommies here, everybody,
everyone bow your head in respect,
every Senpai,
bow your head in respect.
Are you doing it Senpai?
Good,
mommy is off to brush her teeth,
and go to sleep.
Good, good, good,
make sure to floss as well.
Welcome everyone,
welcome to the stream,
I just finished,
not finished, but I,
I just,
temporarily,
put on hold,
my playthrough of
Killer Seven,
in order to yap.
Have fun Mercy,
love you,
love you too,
mommy!
I love you!
Of course,
Strony has like,
super strong endurance.
I,
am still getting used to my schedule,
so my endurance is not as,
as good.
My endurance,
maximum for me,
I can do,
if I'm really enthralled by a game,
is,
the max I did was,
I think I did 12 hours with the max,
and then,
like,
after that I was like,
I'm never doing that again,
so my max,
absolute limit,
is probably 8 hours.
Probably 8 hours.
Killer Seven,
good taste,
thank you,
actually,
I thought I played Killer Seven,
I was like,
yeah, I played Killer Seven,
like,
that's not a 51 game,
right?
Yeah, I played it before,
turns out I played,
Killer is dead,
and that's a completely different game,
so, oops.
Hahaha.
What's the normal gaming session length for you?
Mmm,
I'd say about,
2 to 3 hours.
That's normally what normal is,
unless I'm super enthralled by it,
but, um,
since I,
get a little,
I'm a little bit,
not used to the schedule yet,
and not used to my new routine yet,
I'm,
I'm forcing myself to stop,
within like,
max 4 hours.
Hahaha.
Mostly because,
um,
I have things to do,
and I want to prepare
a lot of things for Senpai.
So I want to be in the best condition for Senpai,
because after like,
maybe the 2 hour mark,
it's kind of,
it's down,
it's downhill from there,
it's just like,
oh my god.
It's zombie mode,
or flow mode,
flow state,
where I'm not even interacting with chat,
or,
you just hear me scream a lot.
You did pick the,
pick the game,
pick up the game,
surprisingly fast.
Well, really?
Is that,
surprisingly fast?
I just read.
I read the instructions,
I'm like,
oh god,
oh god.
I called that disconnect progression.
Oh,
that's a good name for it.
Thank you,
Senpai.
So,
that's why I was like,
oh,
I should probably stop now,
especially since I'm getting a little bit tired
and fatigued.
I think
part of it is due,
is due to,
the motion sickness,
the,
probably the medication wearing off as well.
I did take nausea,
nausea,
meds,
because,
I am training myself a bit
with Killer Seven to,
to,
get used
to motion.
So,
some of those are,
it's probably because,
it's probably I'm,
because of that.
That's my theory.
And that's,
just a game.
So yeah, I was,
I thought to myself like,
oh, well,
I'll just use,
Killer Seven,
and I'll probably try other games too.
Like,
maybe GoldenEye,
to,
to train myself to,
to get used to,
first person stuff.
Do you feel less nervous tomorrow?
No.
Probably this entire week,
I'm going to be a little bit of a,
of a nerve ball.
I'm going to probably be,
a bit of a nerve ball,
the entire,
the entire time.
I might not show it out,
but inside,
I'm definitely like,
I have so many,
I have so many senpais now,
what do I do?
But I definitely want to,
to play games.
I'm actually looking forward,
I think the game that I'm looking forward to the most,
this week,
is,
is Harvester.
Because I love point and click games.
I love point and click games.
Point and click games really,
really make me happy.
I'll tell you,
I'll tell you all a secret, okay?
Strawny says,
I should, I should,
Strawny said,
I should,
play more games than point and clicks.
Do you like transgressive point and click games?
What do you mean by that?
Have you tried tell tales in The Walking Dead?
Not really.
I've tried the wolf among us.
Wolf, the wolf one,
I can't remember what it's really called.
No, not,
not among us, right?
Anyway,
wasn't among us?
Wait, what?
Was it, is it not called that?
It is called wolf among us.
Oh my gosh.
Oh, brain rot.
I was like, oh, shh.
Wow.
Brain rot,
every time I say among us,
among us.
I don't like,
I don't like
quick time events.
That's why I didn't really like that game,
because I didn't like,
I didn't like
quick time events.
I'm still getting used to,
getting used to different formats of things,
because when I do quick time events,
I have to look down
because I'm like, what is the button?
I don't remember which button it is.
What point click titles are under your belt already?
Any classics?
Let me sort out my games.
Let me sort out my games some pie.
Oh my gosh,
how many games do I have in this collection?
I have 118 point and click games
on my Steam library.
Most of it I've already played.
Let's see.
I play
a lot.
A lot of them.
Wait, some of these aren't point and clicks.
Never mind.
Good chunk of them are, though.
The last one I played point and click,
I think,
was Gabriel Knight.
Both,
Gabriel Knight.
Gabriel, Gabriel, Gabriel Knight.
Which one did I play?
The first one,
and then Sins of the Father.
And then
then I played almost all of them,
all of the ones,
almost all of the ones from Watch It Eye.
Uh...
Oh yeah, I remember.
Another one I really loved.
One that I really liked
that I thought was really good
was the Titanic point and click
adventure out of time.
That one was really fun.
What else do I have?
Tango Tower.
Oh wait, no, the last one I played
was not, no, wait, it was Gabriel Knight.
Sorry.
Things are, the one before that
I played was Sanitarium.
Was Sanitarium.
And then the one before that
I think was Salmon Max hit the road.
And then I played,
I played a lot.
I wrote on my debut,
I really liked the Blackwell series as well.
That's also from Watch It Eye.
Yeah, I played, I played a lot.
I played a lot.
Oh yeah, I played
the 8-bit game,
the 8-bit anthology.
So I finished that one.
It wasn't too bad actually.
I thought it would be harder.
And
yeah.
I played quite a bit.
I played a little bit of Disco Legion,
but I totally forgot about it.
Because it's, it's, it's...
It's a game where I need time to play.
Any LucasArp?
Monkey Island?
Yeah, I played Monkey Island.
I think I have Monkey Island.
I played one and two.
I played the Rusty Lake series as well.
I played Shadowgate.
Yeah, I played Shadowgate.
I played a lot.
So I really like,
yeah, I like point and click games.
It's probably my favorite.
Because
have you played I Have No Mouth and I Must Scream?
Yes, I have.
I also read the short story.
I read the short story before I played it.
I played a lot.
I think when I was
a young, a young Mercy, baby Mercy,
um,
what, what happened
in,
what used to happen was
maybe older,
a bit of older supplies will know.
Do you remember the era
when
video games, they would,
they would put CD-ROM games on like everything.
So in like your cereal,
your macaroni,
like you would just get,
get CD-ROM games as a bonus content.
So
that's how I got into point and click.
Because I got,
I got one
called,
from Disney.
Called Hades Challenge.
Called Hades Challenge that I got,
I believe from
a cereal.
And
I've never been the same ever since.
Playing flash games.
Yes, I used to play flash games.
There was one
point and click that no one could solve.
But I was the only one
amongst, amongst my peers
in,
in school, in school, in grade school.
That,
that solved it.
It was called Detention.
Detention.
Three decades ago, that can't be right.
So yeah, I played
that one.
And yeah, I've never,
it's, it's ended up being my favorite genre.
My favorite genre
for games are definitely like,
kind of detective, detective.
That's why I really like a lot of horror,
not, not first person horror.
They make me barf.
I'm sorry.
If,
like,
cosmophobia,
I can't do it.
I have,
I have a game called,
what was this game called again?
Anyways, it's a lovecraftian one.
First person makes me barf.
Can't do it.
That one is
I like horror.
So that's why I like a lot of horror visual novels.
Because I feel like it's unraveling a mystery.
So I like the story,
story aspect of it.
That's why,
that might be a reason why I really like pointing click as well,
is because like,
you kind of unravel the mystery.
I like putting things together.
It's really fun.
I haven't played the full throttle yet.
Um,
the one
I did play
for
Call of Cthulhu
for a pointing click,
which was called prisoner of ice.
I think
it was just called prisoner of ice.
And then I think it got adapted into the Call of Cthulhu
brand.
I'm not sure.
Not sure.
Grim Fandango.
I've already played Grim Fandango.
Yeah.
Um,
Cata,
Categra?
I think I actually have Categra.
I don't know.
Do I have it?
I might not.
I have some,
some games on my wishlist too.
Talking about Call of Cthulhu prisoner of ice.
Yes, yes, yes.
Have you read Dead End?
I guess not yet.
Not yet.
Uh,
the next game I was planning to play
for visual novels was,
what was it called again?
Muv Love.
I was planning to play Muv Love
for my next visual novel.
But,
I might save it
to, to read with some pies.
In the future.
Which Muv Love?
Probably the first one.
I like going in order.
Unless people don't,
unless people don't suggest that,
then maybe I,
I'll play a different one.
Like,
but I'm not really sure.
I have a lot of games I,
I want to play.
There's also,
there's also a bunch of newer games
that I want to play too.
Like, I really want to play
the Princess Peach game.
Like, the Princess Peach game
I really want to play
and I want to play Mario RPG,
the remake one.
So,
there's some,
some games that I really want to play
that are like newer.
Are you interested in fallout games
that are point and click?
The older fallout games?
Really?
First Muv Love
is more rom-com alternative sci-fi one.
Then maybe I'll play alternative instead.
Pay attention!
Pay attention, Senpai!
Didn't you pay attention
to my likes and dislikes before?
I'll have to remind you again!
I'll have to remind my Senpais again!
Silly?
What's on my list?
These are what I have on my list, Senpai!
Memorize it!
You memorizing it?
Yes?
Good!
I gave you a little time.
Good, good, good.
You all memorize it.
That's very good.
Please don't be a quiz on this later.
I just remember...
I just want you guys to remember
which games that I have already said
that are my favorites.
So we don't have any repeats.
Understand?
I'm just kidding.
So those are a lot of games
that are considered the best for me.
I might like things,
but these are the games that I love.
I hope that makes sense.
that are considered the best of the best for me.
I might like things, but like these are the games
that I love.
I hope that makes sense.
Ha ha ha ha!
Have you ever tried Fighting Game?
Yeah.
One Fighting Game I'm only kind of decently okay at
was Tekken.
When I say decently kind of okay, I mean,
I made one person rage quit once and I feel like
that was pretty good.
Oh yeah, I play Kuma by the way.
I play Kuma.
A game that felt pretty good when I played it
as a Fighting Game was Arms.
I really liked Arms.
I would say Arms is a fighting game.
So I really liked the feel of Arms.
I love using the joystick controllers for Arms,
where you like literally punch like wow, wow, wow, wow.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
That felt really good.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
And I was like wow, wow, wow, wow, wow, wow!
Tend to switch arms?
Yeah, that one.
That one felt really good.
I love whacking people using the joystick controllers.
Da da da da da da da da!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
That was really fun.
What's another fighting game that I kind of like?
I kind of really like the feel of Dead or Alive as well.
Is that game still active?
I don't think Arms is still active,
but if you guys make Arms active again,
I might do some training sessions
and I might beat the shit out of everyone.
Ha ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Are you with 2D fighters?
I don't really play 2D fighters, honestly.
The feel of the jiggles, the feel of the game.
I know people are like oh my gosh, that's a porn game.
Blah, blah, blah, blah.
It's all shitty, it's a shitty, sexy lady game.
I have to preach.
I'm just letting you guys know that it feels good.
Like I feel like the impact,
you feel the impact of when they hit each other pretty good.
Does that make sense?
I don't really play any other games
because, well, it's too technical for me.
And I don't really like that.
I don't really like it.
So it's whatever.
That one, yeah.
Yeah, those are the fighting games I enjoy.
Otherwise, I don't really play a lot of fighting games,
mostly because it's kind of required
to play with other people.
I'm kind of a loner.
I'm kind of a solo player.
Ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah.
Um, have you ever played with a PS Vita?
Yeah, a PS Vita was my second console
that I have ever had.
I had a PS Vita before I had a PS4.
Um, yeah.
You tried Monster Hunter before?
This might sound a little weird
coming from, well, a Yandere,
but I feel kind of bad hitting the monsters,
which is why I don't really like Monster Hunter,
or I don't really want to play Monster Hunter.
I feel bad for hitting them.
I think they're really cute.
So I feel bad for hitting them.
You feel bad for hitting us?
Mmm.
Sometimes, but sometimes I feel bad,
but I feel like, you know,
sometimes SEMPAI deserved it,
and sometimes SEMPAI forces my hand.
Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
Sometimes my hand's forced.
I don't want to.
I don't want to hurt my SEMPAI, but, you know,
sometimes you have to.
OK?
Sometimes we, we have to, I, it's always my arm being twisted, it's always my arm being
twisted I never want to do anything but sometimes I always want to run away from me or, or you
know, they do ridiculous things like want to leave so yeah sometimes I have to punish I don't
want to it hurts it hurts my feelings hurts my feelings a whole lot
so when that happens I I might get a little violent I might get a little not violent I'd
rather say I get a little strict yeah yellow strict
oh wait what were we talking about again I am monster hunter yeah I feel bad for hitting them
I feel bad for hitting the them so I I don't really play monster hunter I just feel bad
so I'm trying to think what are we talking about games right games yeah I have like a lot of games
that I want to try playing so I tried to pick a variety of different games that this week that I
personally really like so like an RPG I don't like punishing games but I feel like a difficult game
about climbing is very entertaining for senpai's um because you'll hear me hear me get like really
angry and scream a lot so I warn I'll warn everyone that's a pretty loud that's gonna be a pretty
loud stream so please keep your uh volumes at a fairly low fairly fairly low um fairly fairly low
volume yeah
strategies games oh I get bored with strategy games um
yeah I get bored with uh strategy games I don't think how do I say this senpai I'm not a very
seasoned gamer I don't think I'm ready for Elden Ring yet
I don't think I'm ready for Elden Ring yet so like any souls like games I don't think I'm ready for it yet
because um I've only kind of recently started picking up games again uh
you know uh mercy mom mercy mercy mama mercy papa are a bit strict
so I only recently got a lot of freedom
so I recently only got a lot of freedom and I decided to use that freedom to play games
yeah so I'm still I feel I consider myself a beginner because otherwise the game before
that I played before that were all either just like visual novels and like Pokemon
um so I I'm very late to gaming um my parents never let me have like a sit-down console where
you know you put a home console where you put it on the the tele a tv
that one I've never got got one of those so only when I got older I was allowed to have a
I was all I was allowed to have a handheld system so the handheld system I got was a DS light
the only reason I got a DS light was because mama and papa saw that saw a commercial for big brain academy
and that's the only reason why I was able to get a DS
which pokemon have you played I'm not a big pokemon person so I've only played
Pearl platinum whatever the news soul silver
I think I ended at soul silver
yeah anything after black was like no and I think I picked it up again with
Sword and Shield I don't remember which one I have
I picked it up again with the newer installment I forgot what the newer installment is called
yeah I played the the DS ones yeah
yeah Scarlet and Violet yeah I played I think I have Violet yeah I have Violet
so
yeah I I got a DS because of that and then after I got good grades and stuff I was
allotted to pick I was allowed to pick one game one game that was that I was gonna I'm gonna get
and I picked pokemon pearl that's my second game because everyone loved it and then I lined up I
lined up for the midnight release of pokemon diamond and pearl and then I got pearl because
there was a kid with me who was like pink is for girls so I'm gonna get diamond and so I got I
felt really vindictive at that point and was like fuck you I'll get pearl I'll beat the chair you
know
that's that's what I had decided
I felt I felt really angie about that so I decided to get pearl just to spite him
and so the midnight release was really cool that was my first time doing our midnight release
uh game and then I slowly convinced uh if I kept on getting good grades I would be treated to games
and so I slowly built up a pretty impressive 3ds library I mean not 3ds a DS library sorry
so that's why I am kind of new to gaming I'm kind of new to gaming um my first sit-down console
was a ps4 so yeah I played a back then back then I I was so happy because uh because DS games are
really cheap DS games are really cheap it was so it was so easy to get and now get and now
nowadays I look at the prices of games and go whoa when did that happen
and but yeah eventually I got myself I convinced I convinced um
I'm a kuma and pop a kuma to let me have a PS Vita and then I ended up getting a PSP
for pretty cheap because the Vita came out the Vita came out so I got a PSP as well and then
and then I
I uh
I started to play more gamer games by that time so the gamer games I was playing
Assassin's Creed Liberation I played Persona 3 portable at that time I got I was lucky in stores
one time I saw it was like I think Persona Innocence and I got I started and then I started to
really like the SMT series so then I got really into the SMT series and then when
SMT4 came out I bought the like what was it the beginner not the beginner limited yeah
limited edition version of it and I fell in love with that game I fell in love with SMT4
and then I I tried to play like other games in the SMT series as well and I started to
really like them and then eventually in college college I started to pick up uh retro games because
some of my my gal pals some of my gal pals were like oh well I don't really need I need I'm
making room do you want these consoles and these games and I said yes and then they they gave me
some they they graciously gave me some pretty pretty pog uh retro games and and their systems so
I was really surprised that I was just given given to them so I uh I acquired quite a collection right
now yeah I I acquired such a
uh uh collection are you gonna play Persona 3 Reloaded uh
kind of expensive guys like it's pretty expensive how does retro to you PS1 PS2
PS1 PS2
Gamecube
Nintendo 6v4
yeah
um
yeah um those are retro right
okay uh
uh
yeah those games
I consider them I consider them pretty old right um
I do have console I do have SNES as a console I don't know I don't think I have that many games for
it though um
I don't think I have that many games for it yeah
I have a lot of I have a lot of PS2 games though I have a lot
uh PS2 games
and I would love to play them I love to play them I also have a few PS3 games but I think I have
mostly PS2 games in my collection so those are the games I really enjoyed
uh or at least uh things that I'm gonna try to get into I'm gonna see if I can do streams with uh
like with the native um with the native consoles so that I'm I'm planning to maybe put like a
little CRT on my on my little desk and uh play games from there
so that's why I'm thinking I'm thinking that's what I'm gonna do I want to play the games that
are in the kind of pile of stuff that I already have because yeah I think I don't want to be that
person who keeps on buying games who keeps on buying games and not play them
um
so yeah I am uh the small small one it's not it's a bit heavy but it's not too bad
so I'd like to go through those through games that I already have so if I do have a game that
people have suggested well maybe I'll play it
so that's why yeah I'm thinking I'm hoping I'm hoping I'll be able to get uh what do you call that
and an hd upscaler I think that's what they're called
or borough one whatever borough one permanently I think it's called an hd upscaler uh to stream the
games so hopefully and then I'll find like some ways to to make sure all the games all the system
can be streamed on yeah I've I've done uh I gotta do a little bit of research but I think we can get it
I think we can get it and most of my plans have been um
been uh been kind of like yeah I'll just go through my library my library of games to play
but I did pick up something very special today guys uh some pie sorry
which is I picked up something for the upcoming ASMR stream which is I don't know if it's picking up on my mic
I'm not using the mic so yeah
I'm not using the the the 3dl right now so we can hear it
I picked up some stuff for it
it'll be my first time trying out ASMR
so that's I'm very I'm very new to it so for ASMR I'll
get
I won't be out right
everyone
so it'll be all whispers and I I won't be as loud and I'll try not to laugh as much
so uh if if I laugh it'll be it'll be uh it'll be kind of like
something like that probably I'll try my best to suppress my my
laughter
so I'll try to suppress it just for that just for that stream
so that's why I feel
yeah I feel I feel like I'm going to do my do my best to pamper my supplies
I'm gonna try to pamper my supplies uh I bought a gel mask uh which I think makes a lovely little sound
so I'll massage that that eye mask uh so supplies can have a nice eye massage
and then
and then I have I have these little little ice ice globes that I'll I'll shake and yeah
I'll try my best I'll try my best to give a nice nice soft experience for supplies
well that being said I'm still very new to it so it's uh I might not be perfect so don't
don't don't don't put too much emphasis on it being great or anything it's definitely going to be a
learning curve that's why that's why I want to I want to I want to do my best to to make Senpai happy
and yeah we'll we'll see if if uh if I'm any if I'm okay at it maybe I'll do more
maybe I'll do more ASMR streams depending um unfortunately no no earlickies no earlickies
or anything because youtube's kind of going hard on on the no the no slurp slurp
not like we'll be able to go anywhere of course not I'll force you I'll force you to do it but
I still want I still want my Senpai to be like yes I want to be here you wanted to be here right Senpai
you wanted to be here
yeah I saw Emmys Vaude get cancelled get get get get banished got obliterated obliterated
so I thought oh yeah well time to time to well probably have to I have to be more careful with
ASMR so I'll do something very light and besides I'm kind of training myself to do ASMR stuff so I'll
do kind of the safer work stuff so don't think that it's going to be like the oh my god Senpai
don't think it's the Senpai I'm gonna stick my tongue in your ear now okay don't don't
don't think don't think about don't think it's gonna be like that
unfortunately
please don't think of uh please don't think it's gonna be something like that because uh I'll
probably get bonked I was thinking about doing a salon one in the future as well
so it's like you know snip snip the hair and maybe like a little hair wash
but like be careful don't move or else I'll snap your ears off
so I think um
yeah I can't think of anything else to yap about right now I feel like
I'm gonna be a broken record at this point my brain has been fried
green has been fried from learning killer 7 I'm probably gonna get used to it again don't worry about
it so I'm gonna I'm gonna try my best I'm gonna try my best uh to make all my Senpai's really happy
so yeah oh I feel so I feel a little bit tired I went out and uh go a bit far far to pick up
some of the the ASMR stuff that I wanted to to use for Senpai so it was it was quite it was
quite a far away to pick them up so
I don't know if anyone's streaming or anything right now
I might have to just end stream and not not raid or anything I'm not I'm still not familiar
with YouTube so I don't even know if how to raid very well
now I'm the last one that that that makes sense um that makes sense I I I've decided to take over
the late night stuff because uh in the morning in the morning I want to help out with chores
chores and and uh making sure everything's okay and ready and then I can finally visit my Senpai
in the basement that's why can we be chloroformed before you go are you having trouble uh sleeping
then
having trouble sleeping Senpai
I I do things that are uh I I do late night streams I'm a bit of a night owl actually
maybe I'm more of a afternoon owl I feel more productive within the afternoons to
to early evenings and then the time in the evenings is for me to relax and I feel video games are
sort of relaxing
uh I'm sorry that I always stream late for my Senpais or too early for my Senpai depending on
what time you are but um I did pick this time because it doesn't overlap with most of the girls
um honestly uh
viewer has thought of so much for for Senpais so we want to we wanted to to divide the time so
that there would be someone um taking over a certain time slot each each moment
so I feel like uh I got the night I got the night one because I don't think anyone really picked the
night uh I think Azura and I are kind of the the two night night streamers while I think morning
streams or I think it's night or daytime or icy and then I think strawneys soon soon falls after
and then uh I mean she be so they're they're kind of within like there's always like two girls for
each time you know
so I hope that that at least everyone gets to to meet up with uh with a girl or something
any ideas planned for the future like karaoke yeah I I'm doing karaoke I don't think I plan
karaoke until uh a couple weeks later um I plan my schedule kind of far in advance just so
there'll be time to to make like thumbnails and make sure everything works and schedule
and collabs and stuff so it's a lot
you're actually gonna share us with the others only with VLR
only with VLR because uh
I I legitimately love this company like I really do and I want the best and uh
I truly believe high tides floats off ships uh if you guys understand what that means
so I want every girl to succeed as well
so that's why that's why uh I
I want I want everyone to to have a good time even if I'm sharing my senpai even if I'm
sharing my senpai's but I know deep down that every senpai loves me the most
so yeah
because I really I really hope that everyone falls in love with uh each girl everyone works
really hard I will attest to the fact that all girls work really hard so um I feel like you
don't have to be into all of the girls but I feel like you should in in some way like each of the
girl I hope that makes sense
can I devote myself uh to only you if you want I feel very thankful if you do
uh but I do encourage people to to if if I am your oh she if I am your oh she
uh which I if I I I'm very thankful if if I am your oh she um
thank you for choosing me but I also you know if for example if a if an event or something
or a girl's a girl's having achievement I feel like we should celebrate all together
does that make sense
so I feel like we should still celebrate uh their achievements
um
like not all the girls are are very sweet and I love them all so much I will not have any
VLR slander in here
but yeah if you if you do have a favorite if you do have a favorite I think if it's me
I'm just very honored if it's one of the other girls I'm sure they are also very happy and very
blessed that you have chosen the men's there as uh as their oh she as your oh she so I'm very
very very happy I feel very thankful I see a lot of people I my supplies I see a lot of
some pies say that I'm their favorite which makes me really really giddy really giddy and
kind of shy that's I'm kind of shy about it now
but um yeah I I'm glad
I'm glad I'm glad though so I'm I'm okay to share with everyone
but just remember you are mine when you're here you're mine when you're here with me you're mine
no one else you can talk about some people only if I talk about them otherwise it's just you
all right
so
I'll let you go this time senpai I'll let you go but you'll be back
I had lots of fun playing killer seven uh with everyone I am so happy to be here and I hope
tomorrow's Omori stream will be of interest to my senpai as well um I haven't played Omori to
completion at all I played a little bit of it and then I forgot what happened so it'll be almost
like a fresh take almost I can almost fresh taste and then after that throughout the week I'll be
pretty full uh wow I feel like a broken record now just repeating this uh the following week though
I all streams will be reduced quite a significant quite significantly to about three streams
three streams per and then eventually I'll probably go up up a little bit back to five
up to five streams a week simply because this week I want to keep the hype going I want to
keep the hype going I want senpais to get to know me better I want to know more about my senpais
as well um what everyone's into what you're not into that's what I'm doing so yeah it'll be a lot
of rest rest because oh my gosh I was so stressed and nervous when debut happened like when I stood
up from my chair my legs gave out my legs gave out I was I was wobbly I looked like a dear newborn
dear but yeah thank you everyone for joining me today and I hope you'll not I hope but I know
you'll come back to me okay screen for mercy good night bye bye
uh